ahora vamos a hablar acerca de uno de
los procesos biológicos más importantes
y honestamente si no se diera este
proceso probablemente no habría vida
sobre el planeta tierra yo no podría
estar aquí haciendo este vídeo porque no
podría encontrar comida en ningún lado y
este proceso se llama fotosíntesis y
seguramente tú ya estás muy
familiarizado con este proceso pero lo
que sucede es que las plantas o bueno
también las bacterias y las algas pero
generalmente asociamos a este proceso
con las plantas ok entonces por aquí
nada más voy a escribir plantas y el
punto es que la fotosíntesis es el
proceso que utilizan las plantas para
tomar co2 más un poco de agua h2o
más luz solar y esa la estamos
escribiendo con amarillo las plantas en
la fotosíntesis toman todo esto y lo
transforman en azúcares ok
carbohidratos más oxígeno y como podemos
observar esto tiene dos partes súper
importantes para nosotros como seres
vivos para empezar necesitamos
carbohidratos para darle energía a
nuestros cuerpos eso lo vimos en los
vídeos acerca de la respiración celular
nosotros generamos todos nuestros atp a
través de la respiración celular con la
glucosa la cual es un producto derivado
de los carbohidratos la glucosa es el
carbohidrato que más se nos facilita
procesar durante la respiración celular
y la otra parte muy importante es que
aquí obtenemos oxígeno y bueno
necesitamos respirar oxígeno para poder
hacer la respiración celular
y estas dos cosas de aquí estas dos
cosas son indispensables para la vida
ok son indispensables para la vida que
respira oxígeno y este proceso además de
ser súper interesante el hecho de que a
nuestro alrededor
haya estos organismos que son capaces de
tomar estos elementos y con ellos
aprovechar la luz solar y retener su
energía aunque hay porque tenemos estas
reacciones de fusión a 150 millones de
kilómetros de distancia y esas
reacciones están liberando fotones de
los cuales sólo una muy pequeña porción
llega a la superficie de la tierra
porque tienen que atravesar toda la
atmósfera y algunas nubes por allí y
luego estas plantas y bacterias y algas
son capaces de tomar esos botones junto
con estos elementos y de alguna forma
aprovecharlos para formar algunos
azúcares
y luego podemos llegar nosotros y
comernos esos azúcares o puede llegar
una vaca y comerse estos azúcares pero
después nosotros llegamos y nos comemos
a la vaca claro si es que no somos
vegetarianos pero el punto es que
nosotros podemos utilizarlos como
energía no estoy diciendo que la vaca
sea carbohidratos pero esto es
esencialmente lo que se utiliza como
combustible o como energía para crear
todos los otros compuestos que nosotros
comemos así es que este es como el
combustible para todos los animales y
bueno también si tomamos no sé por
ejemplo una papa ahí estamos obteniendo
nuestros carbohidratos directamente y
bueno esta es una noción muy
simplificada de la fotosíntesis pero no
es como que esté mal si hay algo que
tienes que saber de la fotosíntesis es
esto de aquí
ahora lo vamos a ver un poquito más
profundamente y vamos a intentar
entender qué es lo que está pasando en
el fondo yo honestamente lo encuentro
fascinante que haya unos organismos que
pueden tomar la luz solar y formar estos
azúcares vamos a empezar por escribir
por aquí la ecuación general de la
fotosíntesis básicamente ya está
descrita por aquí pero ahora lo vamos a
hacer de una forma un poco más
científicamente específica
empezamos con dióxido de carbono le
agregamos agua y también agregamos en
lugar de llamarle luz solar directamente
le voy a llamar fotones fotones porque
son estos los que realmente excitan a
los electrones en la clorofila y vamos a
ver todo ese proceso en este vídeo pero
lo vamos a ver con mucha más profundidad
en próximos vídeos el punto es que el
fotón excita a un electrón entonces ese
electrón se va a un estado de energía
mayor y conforme va bajando su nivel de
energía somos capaces de aprovechar esa
energía para producir atp y algunos ndp
haches y luego estos son utilizados para
producir carbohidratos y todo eso lo
vamos a ver muy pronto ahora el repaso
de fotosíntesis es que empezamos con
estos constituyentes y terminamos con un
carbohidrato y el carbohidrato puede ser
una glucosa o también pueden no hacer
una glucosa así es que vamos a poner por
aquí la forma general de describir a un
carbohidrato la cual es poner por aquí
se h2o y luego ponemos por aquí una n
ok porque podemos tener n múltiplos de
esto y generalmente n por lo menos va a
ser 3 y en el caso de la glucosa n es
igual a 6 aunque ya tenemos 6 carbonos
12 hidrógenos y 6 oxígenos
si es que este es el término general
para describir a los carbohidratos y
puedes tener muchísimos múltiplos de
esto de aquí porque podrías tener
cadenas larguísimas pero bueno en la
fotosíntesis terminas con este
carbohidrato
oxígeno y como puedes ver esto que
tenemos aquí no es tan diferente del
primer repaso que vimos de la
fotosíntesis pero a esta ecuación
todavía le falta ser balanceada porque
si tenemos n carbono por aquí entonces
también tenemos que tener n carbonos por
acá así es que vamos a poner una n por
aquí y luego por aquí tenemos 2 n
hidrógenos y para tener 2 n hidrógenos
por acá solo necesito poner una n y en
cuanto a los oxígenos aquí tengo 2 n
oxígenos más n oxígenos así es que en
total tenemos 3 n oxígenos y por acá
aquí ya tenemos n oxígenos y si lo
ponemos aquí una n tenemos otros 2 en
oxígeno y listo ya terminamos de
balancear esta ecuación
y esto de aquí en realidad es un repaso
de lo que sucede en la fotosíntesis pero
visto a una distancia de como 300.000
metros que es un repaso muy general si
lo observamos un poquito más de cerca
nos damos cuenta que esto no sucede
directamente de esta forma primero pasa
por un montón de pasos que finalmente si
nos llevan a estos carbohidratos ahora
en general
podemos partir al proceso de
fotosíntesis fotosíntesis en dos pedazos
y por supuesto lo vamos a ver con mucha
más profundidad en los próximos vídeos
pero primero quiero que veamos un repaso
general y como estaba diciendo la
fotosíntesis se puede dividir en dos
pedazos uno al que le llamamos la fase
luminosa que también lo podemos decir
que es la fase dependiente de la luz y
de hecho esta sería la mejor forma de
describirla así es que también lo vamos
a escribir así fase dependiente de la
luz porque estas reacciones necesitan
que haya luz y después tenemos la fase
oscura aunque este es un muy mal nombre
para esta fase porque también sucede
cuando hay luz aunque también tenemos
esta fase oscura
y la razón por la que estoy diciendo que
este es un muy mal nombre para esta fase
es porque la fase oscura también sucede
cuando hay luz ahora la razón por la que
le llaman la fase oscura es porque no
necesitas que haya luz esa parte de la
fotosíntesis no depende de los fotones
así es que tal vez un mejor nombre sería
fase independiente de la luz así es que
dejémoslo muy claro la fase luminosa si
necesita de la luz solar las reacciones
que se dan en la fase luminosa necesitan
los fotones de la luz solar mientras que
las reacciones de la fase oscura no
necesitan fotones para suceder ok si
pueden suceder cuando hay luz solar pero
no necesitan al sol y por eso podemos
decir que estas reacciones son
independientes de la luz a ver vamos a
dejarlo todavía más claro
fácil luminosa requiere la luz solar
necesita que haya fotones y ahora vamos
a ver una pequeña introducción con la
cual estamos construyendo digamos que un
andamio sobre el que nos podemos parar y
construir algo más grande y sólido en
los próximos vídeos así es que las
reacciones de la fase luminosa
necesitan fotones pero también necesitan
agua así es que el agua entra a las
reacciones de la fase luminosa y al
finalizar estas reacciones obtenemos
oxígeno molecular aunque hay visto por
encima esto es lo que está sucediendo en
las reacciones de la fase luminosa pero
ahora vamos a ver con mucho más detalle
qué es lo que está pasando en el fondo
en estas reacciones y lo que la fase
luminosa produce son moléculas de at&t
que como ya hemos dicho las moléculas de
atp podríamos decir que funcionan como
la moneda de energía
biológico celular la fase luminosa
produce atp pero también produce en a dp
h cuando estábamos estudiando
respiración celular estudiamos unas
moléculas que se llamaban n de h
bueno pues estas son muy parecidas solo
que ahora tenemos esta p por aquí aunque
tenemos este grupo fosfato pero realizan
mecanismos muy parecidos este agente de
aquí esta molécula es capaz de regalar a
este hidrógeno con todo y su electrón
asociado ahora si eres capaz de regalar
un electrón y que alguna otra cosa
obtenga un electrón de más entonces esa
otra cosa está siendo reducida a ver
vamos a escribir por aquí otra vez estás
mnemotecnia o p oxidación es pérdida de
electrones
reducción es ganancia de electrones la
oxidación es pérdida de electrones y
reducción es ganancia de electrones
cierto porque tu carga es reducida
cuando ganas electrones porque los
electrones tienen una carga negativa así
es que este de aquí es un agente
reductor este se oxida a la hora de
perder al hidrógeno con todo y su
electrón y tengo toda una discusión
acerca de los distintos puntos de vista
de la oxidación el biológico contra el
químico pero es exactamente la misma
idea aunque porque cuando pierdo un
hidrógeno también estoy perdiendo la
capacidad de acaparar al electrón de ese
hidrógeno así es que esto de aquí cuando
reacciona con otras moléculas es un
agente reductor regala este hidrógeno
con todo y el electrón asociado a ese
hidrógeno y entonces la otra cosa se
reduce por lo que es
es un agente reductor agente reductor y
ahora lo que es útil acerca de esto es
que cuando el hidrógeno y especialmente
el electrón asociado a este hidrógeno
cuando éstos se dan con alguna otra
molécula el electrón pasa a un estado de
energía más bajo y esa energía se puede
utilizar en la fase oscura y como vimos
en la respiración celular
la molécula que se parece mucho nh a
través del ciclo de krebs o bueno de
hecho mucho más importante a través de
la cadena de transporte de electrones
esa molécula es capaz de ayudar a
producir atp conforme sus electrones
pasan a un estado de energía más bajo
pero por el momento no quiero
confundirte tanto así es que nos vamos a
quedar con que las reacciones de la fase
luminosa necesitan fotones toman agua y
escupen oxígeno también escupen atp y nh
los cuales se utilizan después
la fase oscura ya las reacciones de la
fase oscura para casi todas las plantas
se les llama el ciclo de calvin ciclo de
calvin y por supuesto vamos a ver con
muchísimo detalle todas las cosas que
suceden en el ciclo de calvin pero como
un resumen rápido antes de entrar en
detalles el ciclo de calvin toma
moléculas de atp y n
de ph y produce no precisamente
moléculas de glucosa pero si produce una
molécula que seguramente ya has visto en
algún lugar una molécula que se llama
pegar aunque hay el ciclo de calvin
produce pegar aunque bueno a esta
molécula también se le puede llamar g 3p
y pegar es la abreviación de fósforo
literal de ido
fue willy será leído mientras que ge 3p
es la abreviación de glee será leído 3
fosfato
y será el de ido tres fosfato
son dos abreviaciones de exactamente la
misma molécula que podríamos dibujarlo
por aquí aunque esto que voy a hacer es
una sobre simplificación exagerada pero
el pedal de 3 p tiene 3 carbonos y un
grupo fosfato ok pero repito esta es una
forma exageradamente simple de
representar a esta molécula y lo
interesante del pedal del g3 p es que
esto se puede utilizar para formar otros
carbohidratos incluyendo a la glucosa si
tomamos dos moléculas de estas podemos
producir glucosa así es que hagamos un
último repaso de todo esto
vamos a ver vídeos de la fase luminosa y
otros vídeos de la fase oscura pero por
ahora hagamos un último repaso general
fotosíntesis la fotosíntesis empieza con
fotones recuerda que todo esto puede
suceder con la luz solar
pero solo las reacciones de la fase
luminosa necesitan que haya fotones las
reacciones de la fase luminosa toman los
fotones y más adelante vamos a ver con
detalle qué es lo que realmente está
sucediendo aquí pero bueno también toman
moléculas de agua producen moléculas de
oxígeno y también producen moléculas de
atp idn a dp h las cuales son utilizadas
por las reacciones de la fase oscura o
sea por el ciclo de calvin ok éstas son
utilizadas por las reacciones
independientes de la luz y decimos que
son independientes de la luz porque
aunque estas reacciones sí puedan
suceder cuando tenemos la luz solar no
necesitan de los fotones para ocurrir y
entonces son independientes de la luz
así es que las reacciones de la fase
oscura toman estas moléculas junto con
algunas otras moléculas que vamos a ver
con mucho detalle que por cierto se me
olvidó un constituyente es súper
importante para el ciclo de calvin y
este es el dióxido de carbono el ciclo
de calvin necesita dióxido de carbono de
aquí es de donde salen todos estos
carbonos con los cuales podemos producir
fósforo visceral de i2 también conocidos
como billie ser aldehído 3 fosfatos así
es que este dióxido de carbono es súper
importante así es que la fase oscura el
ciclo de calvin toma dióxido de carbono
junto con estos productos de la fase
luminosa atp y nh y con todo esto
produce este muy simple bloque de
construcción con el cual podemos
construir otros carbohidratos si te
acuerdas de cuando estábamos viendo
glucólisis puede ser que te acuerdes de
esta molécula pega
o 3 p es exactamente lo mismo pero
seguramente te acuerdas de que este es
el primer producto de cuando partimos a
la glucosa en dos a través de la
glucólisis bueno pues aquí estamos en la
dirección contraria estamos construyendo
glucosa para después poder dividirla en
dos y obtener su energía así es que este
es un repaso muy rápido de la
fotosíntesis y en los próximos vídeos
vamos a ver con mucha más profundidad
las reacciones de la fase luminosa y de
la fase oscura y vamos a ver con mucha
más profundidad cómo es que realmente
suceden